tu sais où aller qu'il y allait aller
voir un mètre sur moi pas vous inquiéter
ses cris ça c'est son copain itération
de ma fille je te dis c'est ton fils qui
les lui a donné tu as bien de qui ça
veut dire quoi bien sûr que je vais la
chercher cette gamine qui fera quoi si
tu la retrouves et qu'elle veut parvenir
des cnam parce que c'est moi le
kidnappeur maintenant il va pas faire la
très intéressante à noël crois qu'apple
fasse calme mais ça marche pas comme ça
la compagnie opère partout
la légende continue à chercher c'est toi
le français qui cherche sa fille
j'ai entendu parler de gens à sedan des
passeurs c'est m c'est kenny fille
acolytes
c'est comme ça qu'un s'appelle maman
lt au yémen au danemark en turquie ça
t'a servi à quoi les nouveaux faut y
aller tiens rien
je te dis pas d'arrêter de chercher je
pourrais faire une cause mais je vais
rentrer chez moi avec ma fille estelle
doctorat
m
x